It's been 22 years
since the events in the first movie
and that means anyone younger than 22 in
a world that we're creating
has never lived in a world where
dinosaurs didn't exist.
They're coming into this with this idea
the dinosaurs are not really that fascinating.
(Corporate felt genetic motification would up the 'wow' factor.)
(They're dinosaurs 'wow' enough.)
What does Jurassic World need to do to build a bigger attendance?
They need to make is bigger, faster, more scary.
(That was awesome!)
The character that I play, Claire, she runs
the park. And she's someone who is very
disconnected from her own humanity
because in the quest for profit she
makes some disastrous mistakes.
(You just went a made a new dinosaur?)
(Probably not a good idea.)
(Screaming)
We shot this movie for IMAX. And so our aspect ratio is the native ratio
of all the digital IMAX screens in the
world
So when you see our film the whole thing
takes up the entire screen.
It's a pretty stunning experience. You really
do feel the difference.
(You got 20,000 people.)
(You got no more boats. You don't have enough guns.)
There's so many sequences in this, that I'm excited to see especially in IMAX.
The Mosasaurus, the underwater stuff, the
'raptor motorcycle sequence
I think that's going to be pretty great. (If we do this, if we do this my way.)
Basically, everything! It's just such an iconic
franchise and there are so many people that love
it so much so it's been quite the honor
to be a part of it.
(We're talking about an animal here.)
(A highly intelligent animal.) It's crazy like there
were so many moments
on set where all of us felt like we're
all kids in our backyard making a
dinosaur movie. Like this is such a wish fulfillment for
someone who saw the original film. It was just an enormous blast.